Prince Harry has led from the front
throughout his tour last engagement the
center bar a polo cup kitted up ready
for action but first things first and
embraced between the prince and his
Argentine adversary nacho figures the
first chucker had barely begun and there
was a faller the Prince the first to
leap to his assistance Harry's shot may
have been off target this time but he's
had a steady grip on events from the
Caribbean to Brazil it's been an
emotional trip 10-12 days I'm absolutely
exhausted but the warmth of reception
that we've we've received from every
single country being to and including
Brazil has been utterly amazing you
can't sit there with a stiff up and let
me acosta crosstabs and not get involved
we need from the start that these
countries were going to be fantastic fun
I've never taken myself too seriously
and so I hope that everyone back home
you lose as soon as it is and as I said
you know I've had an amazing time I've
had a guest and on behalf of my
grandmother so romneya hopefully
everyone's happy the Prince Harry this
is not just a moment to indulge in one
of his loves after ten days of working
it's also a chance to maximize attention
on one of his other passions is charity
in Lesotho to the victor the spoils and
Harry seemed pleased with his from a
Victoria's Secret model job done for his
charity job done for Her Majesty but now
it's back to the day job for Captain
Harry Wales as Afghanistan lunes it
won't be long before fairies fresh
approach is back on tour again Paul
Harrison Sky News South power
you